let's just start with our breaking news
that the former footballer dennis law
has just announced that he has dementia
law is one of the few players who played
for both manchester city and manchester
united and says that he's had a
difficult year with long periods of
isolation
he broke the british transfer record
when he signed for city in 1960 and at
manchester united only wayne rooney and
bobby charlton have scored more goals
than he has
he says he's been diagnosed with mixed
dementia which is more than one type of
dementia and says in my case this being
alzheimer's and vascular dementia in a
statement he also said you hope it won't
happen to you even make jokes about it
whilst ignoring the early signs because
you don't want it to be true however the
time has come to tackle this head-on
excuse the pun
i do understand what is happening and
that is why i want to address my
situation now whilst i'm able because i
know that there are days when i don't
understand and i hate the thought of
that right now and of course law is just
the latest in a number of footballers
who've either announced that they're
suffering uh from dementia or have
passed away uh as a result of it and
there have been a number of studies of
course linking dementia to the injuries
that can be sustained to the brain
through heading a ball over time